the Joe Rogan experience it just mean
you know like with this point system
this and that I try I always try to
finish fights no matter what even if you
the best kind where I don't try to
finish you and you always assume in your
face I'm not gonna go away because
that's just it you know like if I if we
fought to death if there's no time limit
I'm good like I'm gonna kill you
like this is my mindset like there's no
way I'm gonna figure out a way to make
you tired can it make you quit and when
you quit you know you know may peace be
with you to the next one but at the end
of the day that's what it is that's why
you you should be in that moment because
if your freshness that everybody can be
the greatest fresh but there's a special
ones that know how to figure it out when
they're not there like when you're tired
and you're dead tired you gotta go that
warm around the extra minute you figure
things out and that's what that's what
separates the great from the greatest
you know this is the difference I think
well that's always been a real signature
of your fighting style is your endurance
and your confidence in your intern so
you could push through that I'll never
forget the rematch with Aldo when right
before the second round you came over to
us and you went the man's tired I felt
I'm going already and then when I came
down when I came by you and I was like
the man's tired cuz I knew I was like
this guy's done he's done he came out I
remember he came out fast he came up
fast like a straight right left foot and
I was like maybe he might not be but
we're gonna find out right now and then
I pushed in Livermore and I was i okay
yeah yeah yeah that was a little
smokescreen here that's what he had left
from the little minute he got to he got
to rest you know couldn't fight that's
his style is so explosive yeah he
couldn't fight that way with you and
that was a perfect example of styles
make I like what you said I like what
you said like I want in a dog fight
knowing that I'm gonna come out on a dog
fight like that I won't bring the fight
to him and that's what that's what
that's what we knew you know I knew that
I had forced him into action yeah I knew
that if I got into a couple of slugs
with him every time I went every time I
came out my
probably drop 2% but he's dropping like
30 why is that
I did the dude is genetically gifted
with power hmm with power you know and I
knew it I know I knew that I was in it I
was in him for longing and if you watch
his last is a lot of his fights I got to
that's the cool thing about him like I
got to watch I got to watch him when I
was 16 I've been watching 16 and now I
got to face this guy like I always told
myself like even before I was in MMS I
want kickbox this guy if I could fight
him for five rounds I could beat him in
a kickboxing match that is what I told
myself you know just is the belief you
need to be great you know and keep
pushing in because you just watch him
you can just see me attire over time you
know I said he win the first three
rounds fort fit he just coasted yeah
yeah the the gifted with powers so true
because those guys were gifted with
power rarely have the cardio saying yeah
yeah like there's there's a lot of guys
there that I just think like gosh I wish
I had your power if I could just have
give me 2 percent of your power right I
would love that you know but and we work
you know I'm working for I try I'm
trying to get it but just I get just God
give it like this is different like this
some guys this god-given power they just
touch each it boo people's likes a
little said for the kind of endurance in
the style that you have that style of
constant pressure but I like this my
style and stuff like I like it because
like when you do knock out someone they
can always be like oh he just caught me
you know like with the Aldo and stuff
the first one that's what they're saying
there's like yeah Mac she's losing the
first couple rounds but you just caught
him so the second time we did back we
ready that we running back and I had to
do what I do you know I want to show
everybody look I'm here for real
but that's why I like my style but like
yeah you do good but I'm like and what
like if you knock out somebody like
catch them early in the round say five
seconds in akumal you can be like yeah
you just caught a lucky punch even if it
was the most calculated punch in the
world you know even like what the corner
didn't like this is the lucky punch
there's not a lucky punch you know
Connor is in the back practicing it you
know I mean like you see it wasn't a
lucky punch but people keep telling them
know it land is lucky blah blah so it's
always gonna be whatever you know over
your head whatever but
the way I fight and stuff I just want to
just outclassed you in every single way
that I possibly can and show the world
like so you wanna you wanna wrestle yeah
try and get me there you wanna do Jiu
Jitsu yeah take me down let's see let's
see if you can get me there first and
then if you want to do the striking
thing yeah let's do it you know I just
want to show the world that look I'm
varying you in every aspect so like
mentally that that just screws with
someone you know do you think that a guy
that has the kind of power that Aldo has
can ever have the kind of endurance that
you have for sure you know but they
fight different yeah for sure you know
but in the back in their back pocket is
just tough because sometimes when those
guys mindsets I feel like with the guys
who get knocked out who has knock apart
or mind says they turned to light they
tend to like I just gotta land this yeah
so so that's why and then and then you
get tired in there like that because
then you mentally fatiguing yourself cuz
you thinking about like oh [ __ ] I'm
having bad night now I just change it I
got turning in now you start you start
getting tanned you start looking for
that one shot you start missing that
shot and like even when I fought
although you was calling a lot I like
look he's like he's missing like when
you miss a punch and your body goes with
it it's tough it's tough to recover it's
like oh my gosh and then you don't put
in the the extra five percent that might
get you more time because you thinking
like why like I just missed where is
this kid you know like what is he doing
then I'm back right on you you know so
or anybody like they're back in your
face like I'm here you know knock knock
hello Utah laughs no all right
[Applause]